we are here with an audience of teachers
and the first lady of the United States
Dr Jill Biden
among the grade school for most of us
were show and tells science fair
projects and of course spelling beasts
love them in honor that we thought today
would be a good time for the second
almost annual Kelly spellies
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
as for as first teacher of the United
States Dr Biden has graciously agreed to
host
um RB as pronouncer so that means I need
a competitor and I have a good one I am
very excited about this for 23 years he
hosted Reading Rainbow and this year he
hosted the Scripps National Spelling Bee
you can catch his podcast LeVar Burton
reads wherever you get your podcast
please everybody I'm very excited
welcome LeVar Burton
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
yes okay so Levar who was your favorite
teacher as a kid um third grade Hano
American Elementary School in uh in in
Germany hanau Germany Mrs Twiggs
um she was the first person outside of
anyone in my family who realized and
acknowledged that I had a talent
whenever she wanted to go to the
teacher's lounge to make herself a cup
of tea she would give me a book put me
in front of the class and I would read
because I was the best reader in the
third grade
uh also clever play she gets to go get
some tea and you're holding down the
classroom that's the smart woman
um well maybe she's just having martini
That's my kind of teacher
Levar and I need teammates so we have
two competitors from this year's Scripps
National Spelling Bee Championship I'm
very excited first up is Kirsten she's a
seventh grader up from Richmond Texas
she's
qualify
she'll be on team Lavar oh I'm getting a
hug too you're too cute huh you are
mustard too look how cute you look all
right we also have Justin he's an eighth
grader from Diamond Bar California
[Applause]
he's on team Kelly oh I have this oh yes
he was like all business y'all he was
like put it on
like we're gonna win all right we'll
meet the first lady that's not every day
um and LeVar Burton
um so Kirsten is this true that you're a
spelling wait you're a spelling champion
in two languages yup
I was I was the national Spanish
spelling me champion in 2019 and this
year I participated in the Scripps
National Spelling Bee when I achieved
fifth place wow
I speak four languages English Spanish
Mandarin and Tagalog and I love the
spell even if my future profession is a
nearest surgeon
something also guys I really really
really love to see
wait wait hold on hold on button boom
you made my team
Mr Jackson you've been competing and
spelling bees for a while right I've
been competing and spelling bee since
first grade where I got out on the word
physicist I didn't remember it had four
s's or 15 s's so I just added a couple
extra to be safe I love that you still
remember it you're like I bet you know
how to spell it now you'll never get to
forget it
I love that I love it okay so the rules
are we'll go one at a time Kirsten and
Justin will spell usual spelling bee
words uh but Lavar and I will have to
spell the names of famous people because
I'll be humiliated if we do real things
the winning team will receive five
thousand dollars in scholarship money
for the students
so Dr Biden who's who's got the first
word or celebrity name okay so the first
word goes to Justin ready okay okay so
the first word is Labradoodle oh that's
a hard one Labradoodle they have the
definition sure it's a dog that is a
cross between a Labrador and a poodle
um they have the language of origin the
word is a blend of Canadian geographical
name and a German word
uh can you repeat the word one more time
sure Labradoodle Labradoodle
l a b r a d o o d l e
[Applause]
yay
[Applause]
[Laughter]
okay so the next word goes to Kirsten
and the word is Shenanigans Shenanigans
what's that mean Shenanigans means
high-spirited uh much like you I swear
or mischievous Acts oh yeah I don't
think I got that mischievous but other
than that I think I got a lot of
shenanigans
shenanigans
s h
e n a n
i g a n s shenanigans
what's what's even better Dr Biden is
that I totally knew how to spell that
too
totally I was like I have no idea
okay Dr Biden who gets who gets the next
the next word or you do okay thank you
Kelly are you ready in advance okay okay
here's your word okay Streisand
oh my God I love Barbara
um can I spell her first name
um
um can you use it in a sentence no I'm
just kidding
um as I'm thinking if there's two s's
I'm stalling oh okay
asked did that help you drawing I'm
gonna try it okay okay as I've watched
both of you yeah s t r
I e
s tries in i-e-i
Streisand
s-t-r-i-e-s-a-n-d I don't know how
we won't tell Barbara it's
okay dang it so we were looking for
s-t-r-e-i-s-a-n-d yeah but that's not
what you got
I love you Barbara
I can see yourself I can't spell your
name okay
okay who's next okay Lavar are you ready
for your work I am doctor okay so it's
Johansson
as in Scarlet
no pressure j-o-h-a
in
in s o n
all right sorry
I was too excited
j-o-h-a-n-s-s-o-n happens to all of us
happens to the best of us
wow
you just made me feel good about myself
I was gonna be the only loser over here
I was like wait okay so so the score is
it's one to one to one because we are
the weakest link
so it looks like we have a tie
um and there are no losers on the Kelly
Clarkson show and in Kelly's bellies
anyway so Kirsten and Justin you're both
getting five thousand dollars
it buddy you didn't use it
and that's not all
that's not all I know y'all have heard
of adobe Express it's a free design app
that helps students and teachers create
anything from posters to flash cards
with ease well our friends at Adobe know
that you dig into your own Pockets I
know my mama did for school supplies and
all that so to help they're giving every
teacher in our audience a one thousand
dollar Visa gift card
foreign
you're also getting a free one-year
Adobe Express premium subscription to
use at home to start creating today
[Applause]
champion of education and teachers
everywhere so give it up for one more
time
what I'm liking coming up next I love
you Barbara
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]